and I'll like Brangelina or you know
Bennifer or our name is crunch
we've decided I'm not sure why seemed
you know long and long long winded so
crunch felt efficient and do you use
grunt a lot Christmas cards like
Christmas with the crunch now I suppose
there'll be a whole new generation of
kids who fall in love with this Mary
Poppins and so Emily are your kids how
are they with it well I think um I mean
my youngest my two year old has a sort
of attention span of a fly so she
watches the trailer but hazel who's
almost five has seen it and just
absolutely loved it and sort of wants to
talk about it all the time now and yeah
it was really if your mother is Mary
Poppins I do think she's C I think she
just thinks it's normal she's like well
that's what this is what Sunny's mummy
does and this is what my mummy does you
know it's just sort of like quite
conversational for her is it gonna help
or hinder discipline at home Oh hinder
really yeah I think so
because she knows she already knows I
can't fly she's like what she's baby but
she did ask me to do the voice the other
day just out of nowhere because she was
quite sort of impassive watching the
film just sort of didn't just sort of
didn't reveal much of what she felt and
then the other day she goes do your
she's American of course sounds American
she good she good she goes do Mary
Poppins voice and I go spit-spot and off
we go and she goes
[Applause]
to me in the bathtub well where I say to
the to the dolphin no no not yet and now
the two of them go no not yet smooth of
course I have a signature dance me what
is it what is it it's in order to dance
without getting hurt I stretch so I just
make the stretching into the dancer oh
it's called the lunge
no no it's sure yeah that would be like
everything
[Music]
[Applause]
okay that's how I met Donna do you have
one don't have please do something after
that she said you're the best
oh that's she said I pulled the quad so
I hope not
oh no I mean I did that it's go I did a
level French but since gone out the
window but I I get really nervous
speaking French and actually used to
have a stutter when I was a kid and it's
still the way that that I still start oh
when I have to speak French yeah we went
to Paris for New Year once and and you
know my now husband and our two friends
were like go and find us a taxi because
we need to get to this place I said oh
god please don't make me please don't
make me and I didn't had the guts to
tell them actually I do still stutter
they were like go on please and so I
went to the guy at the front desk I was
like I could say everything apart from
the word taxi apparently so I went um
excuse you well and and you went taxi
and I wait yes anyway taxi he's Simon
English silent
Emily wants to be in absolutely but as a
director is it then weird giving your
life-partner notes it was weird because
I was very nervous about to be honest I
think we both were before we started
shooting she said are you nervous and I
said I'm terrified and she said oh good
me too
um I think it's one of those things
where people think because we're both in
the same business we have the same
experiences but I've actually never been
on set with her seen how she worked I'd
heard she was a diva and I just can't
get Emily out of her trailer stuff I had
it's like and nobody I think what it was
is and it sounds really sappy but it's
true I think it's the greatest
collaboration I've ever had in my career
I've never seen her work and when you
are actually in the room and she does
what she does it honestly it changes the
air in the room everyone is just
completely and totally stunned by what
she does
I have to learn early on in our oh
that's relationship is that British
people are notoriously terrible at
taking compliments would you agree just
like
actually what she did I just want to get
out of the way I'm a huge fan here's
we're cool at all there was none of that
actually I don't know your work you are
a proper fan no I was full stalker
status yeah
I was just like hey you want to go out
with me how many times have you seen
Devil Wears Prada I mean not 75 give or
take 72 it's one of those things that
back in the day us elderly people used
to chant and no one does that it's just
one of those movies that whatever
whenever you're going through the
channels you just stop and you mean look
as anyone seen the film here there's a
sort of montage sequence where Annie
Hathaways got numerous fabulous outfits
that they go through and John one day I
came home and he was watching it and and
he was watching the montage but he goes
that's my favorite outfit
I couldn't get an e you got to spend
time here absolutely yeah
now is it correct we need to apologize
we worry not that welcoming to you know
most people are so welcoming customs
agents not so much no I went up to when
she was shooting I was shooting
something in Montreal so I flew back to
see the kids and and my wife and I
remember customs everything was fine and
and then one week just got unlucky and
there was a guy about my age
seemed a bit grumpy and he said you see
he said yeah he said you're an actor and
I said yeah he goes what do I know you
from and I said I don't know if you'd
know I mean we did the American version
of your British office strike one
I loved that show the UK version I get
it I get it and then he said who you
visiting simply wife and he said she an
actress and I said yeah he said what I
know her I said I don't know and he said
what's her name and I said Emily Blunt
as he was writing something anyway you
like stamped my passport here John also
I did encourage him that he would be
welcome more if he stopped wearing a
baseball cap because I just said you
look so American that makes it better
prejudices work he went out and bought
himself a tweed flat cap no we look good
we know like something out of a Guy
Ritchie film you look great
and he walked down the street and it was
like the Sun came out cuz suddenly a guy
turned him anyway you lose the baseball
hat just weed that's what it says and
was it nice because you'll be having
your children spending time here quite
nice because are they American children
you said it kind of sneering me put your
cap off you'll be fine no dry heaves you
were like our America
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean semi American they do become
quite well my oldest daughter became
quite British sounding over the course
of the year that I was here for Mary
Poppins and she was sort of saying
things like bath and water and now she's
back to water
[Music]
you